now the us is preparing to announce
another 800 million dollars in military
assistance for ukraine delighted to be
joined in the studio by the interim us
ambassadors uk that's philip rieka so
much to talk about first of all thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the program i'm gonna have to put my
glasses on because my eyes that's not
what it used to be
we've all been there
good morning to you i wonder if i could
start uh with a conversation about boris
johnson please if i may president
zielenski as saying that he is an
example and he is helping more than
other leaders in his words um
parliament's meantime as you know is
calling for him to resign um
what's washington's view of partygate
i think for washington what has been
most important in these days and you saw
it yesterday with the call that
president biden convened of g7 and other
leaders to discuss the latest efforts in
ukraine and what we're doing incredibly
well knitted up to help ukraine and that
includes of course the uk which has been
tremendous has shown leadership
in our efforts to support ukraine under
vladimir putin's brutal
violations this war of choice that putin
has chosen to attack the ukrainian
people its sovereignty thinking he could
divide the west
and indeed the west has been remarkably
united more than i think many expected
under the leadership of leaders like
those from the g7
and providing on a daily basis
what ukraine needs
to fight this war what they are doing to
defend themselves their sovereignty
even though we see every day more brutal
action
in a sort of medieval way from vladimir
putin so washington doesn't have a view
about the internal politics in the uk we
deal with the world as we find it every
day
we watch with interest
the uk has
politics just as we have in in the
united states and the uk has
institutions this is the marvel of
democracy as we experience it would the
russian people could uh express
different views and debate i don't think
there's much discussion about
what vladimir putin does on any given
day as we see what he inflicts upon
ukraine in a different way then um
does washington
find our prime minister to be
trustworthy i think they work well with
the leadership in the uk
the
the coordination is just remarkable what
i watch every day from nine elms from
our embassy here leading
uh the the team uh which engages with
the uk at a whole of government level
is watch as our leaders speak our
ministers speak
coordinate with the ukrainians in terms
of how we help them but in dealing with
all the other challenges we have in the
world these days every day presents
great challenges in terms of
transatlantic security global security
uh and we have no better partner than
that than the united kingdom and as far
as that is concerned you find boris
johnson to be a trustworthy ally i think
we work with uh every day with the
leadership here we've had a very good
cooperation remarkable unity within the
alliance
the leadership in the g7
cop 26
and of course what we've all dealt with
in terms of covet 19 these letters and
numbers that have defined certainly the
uh the ten months that i've been in
great britain is that a yes mr
ambassador no it is that we will keep
working on this most important
relationship there's no other
relationship like it truly uh what the
u.s and the uk do on a daily basis and
i've been able to see that
really in spades from where i sit what
would happen if we changed leaders
during
the situation as we see in ukraine at
the moment what difference would that
make for the united states we deal with
uh the day as we find it every morning
and uh it's a little early now in
washington but i think yeah my
colleagues will be waking up they'll be
watching sky news they'll be looking for
the latest uh from the britain just but
just as you do
and what's happening in washington in
our politics uh in our foreign policy
and
my job as a diplomat leading the team
here
is to make sure that we are doing our
utmost to make the most out of this
relationship to strengthen it uh and
work on behalf of obviously the people
of the united states but here with our
great partners the people of the united
kingdom how do you think the nato
relationship overall is is working when
it comes to dealing with the situation
in ukraine
it is remarkable to see how the
alliances come together vladimir putin
thought that he would find a divided
west divided alliance that he would be
able to drive wedges he was sorely
mistaken
and what is great about our democracies
those that uh the 30 countries that are
in nato and our other partners
is that we can have the raucous debates
we can have the
white tops on the rough seas that we've
seen in past years in the alliance uh
airing differences and approaches but in
the end we've actually made the alliance
stronger we've seen that in the
extraordinary summit that was held just
a couple weeks ago
in brussels i think we'll see it again
in madrid when the heads of state and
government meet
uh
from nato to uh to look at a way forward
and they meet regularly electronically
as well that's right and uh we use other
structures like the g7 the group that
convened yesterday to discuss the latest
you mentioned
the latest round of
military support that we are providing
to ukraine the humanitarian support for
what is really a
truly uh awful situation as we've seen
what uh vladimir putin has inflicted
upon the people of ukraine i mean there
has been i think it's fair to say a very
clear step change when it comes to sort
of lethal support that you were offering
president zielinski
what's happened for you to decide that
that is the right way forward i think
there's been a constant dialogue and
consultation with the ukrainian
leadership on what they need and i think
what we've seen is this also remarkable
effort by the ukrainians a profile
encouraged not only their leader
president zielinski who might met and
know
but ukrainian people
i saw in zielenski even as a candidate
someone different who had great
qualities of leadership and that's what
we're seeing now
uh and i think he's an inspiration not
only to his own people which is most
important but to so many of us
and just like in the united states here
in the uk the outpouring of support
uh the understanding it recalls another
era frankly when we were brutalized by
dictators by fascists
and vladimir putin is doing a good job
of repeating some of those historical
wrongs we've spoken before uh mr
ambassador and we're honored to have you
again last time we spoke uh you refused
to rule out u.s troops entering uh
ukraine
um
what would it take for u.s troops to go
into ukraine clearly that's a decision
for the president and he's been very
clear about that we are not going to
we are not going to uh to war with
russia we want to support ukraine we
want to of course protect uh our allies
who are under nato who do fall under the
article 5 the sacred bond
that has made nato so successful for
these 70 plus years in terms of
defending an area
of peace nato a defensive alliance
threatening no one not threatening
vladimir putin not threatening russia
and here you have in fact putin
attacking
russian-speaking cities like kharkiv
and so we will continue to support the
ukrainian people who again have shown
this remarkable
resilience
and i think that's been a surprise
uh to putin uh in his calculus obviously
a lot of miscalculation on his part
um i've been speaking to quite a few um
previous ambassadors on the show over
the last couple of days they've all been
warning about concerns about nuclear
capability of russia how seriously does
america take it
well as our
director of central intelligence bill
burns a former ambassador and state
department official whom i know well
said in open testimony last week this is
something we have to be concerned about
putin himself has has raised this
so certainly it's something we have to
watch very closely the the kind of
brutality
that putin has enacted we've seen it
before
but it's hard to imagine
what he's doing and it seems like
there's there's very little
uh
that
would stop him
particularly when he makes those kinds
of threats do you think he's capable of
a nuclear strike i think we're seeing
that vladimir putin is very
unpredictable
has been out of touch miscalculated
terribly and what we need to do is
maintain the unity of our alliance
in terms of defending uh
our
interests and supporting ukraine and
their efforts to protect their
sovereignty their independence and their
very lives
i recently spoke to a very um higher
politician here in the uk and i said you
know why we're not being tougher with
russia and he said because he's got
nukes
i think there's a calculation you have
to make and president biden has shown
remarkable leadership from the beginning
if you followed his campaign if you
followed him as a senator as vice
president
he never saw vladimir putin for anything
than what he is and what he's showing
himself to be today but the president
was very ready to
work with putin he made that clear he
wanted a more predictable more stable
relationship from the first day of the
presidency
last year
when he came into office president biden
extended the new start treaty not for a
year or some months but for five years
he created a strategic stability
dialogue so putin could raise the issues
that seem to concern him we still
can't see where he feels he has some
threat to his security no what putin
was afraid of was democracy and the
president made that clear too last march
when he spoke about this inflection
point that we face between democracy and
autocracy and how we have to show that
democracy can deliver and i think we in
the west
have unified around that purpose the
institutions of democracy that may be
different among us are working not only
to defend our interests but to promote
and support the ukrainians but how
cautious does president biden need to be
not to poke that russian bear because
he's talked about him being a dictator
he's talked about genocide he's talked
about regime change he
it seems to me that president putin
needs to be offered an off-ramp and when
you start to throw those allegations at
him it's just poking him i think he's
had an off-ramp at every moment if you
go back
and look at all of the discussions as we
put forward the intelligence
we made in an extraordinary way
declassifying intelligence information
to show the world what putin was
preparing to do to tell the ukrainians
you've got to be aware of what's
happening on your border
we
continuously talked about looking for
diplomatic solutions off-ramps if you
will
say that's not diplomatic language i
think we have to also tell the truth and
we see it your reporters are there
showing these graphic horrible pictures
of things no one expected in europe in
2022 and vladimir putin who claims to be
trying to defend
some interest some some russian interest
is murdering
russian speakers
is bombarding them in a truly medieval
way
on a daily basis we see now in the the
east as he uh moves again on the donbass
uh
what is really brutal
so we have to make clear that we see
what's going on that there has to be
responsibility and accountability but
also make clear that diplomacy had
always been the option and the answer
and putin himself can work with the
narrative that he decides he controls
what his people hear
and frankly what they think
um i saw yesterday that president biden
apparently has said that he's going to
run again
at the next election what do you think
i think he'll make that decision when
the time comes and uh you know our
institutions our elections are very
clear and set every four years we have
a clear election date
and a clear date when the
president is sworn in
whether reelected or a new president as
we've seen just in the past couple of
years the world watches that americans
watch that i think we're proud of our
our institutions uh living by our
constitution to form a more perfect
union never having said we've got
looking at his age there he'll be a
couple of weeks off 82 at the next
election is now the time to potentially
move aside for a younger candidate i
think the president has to make that
decision and ultimately it's the voters
in the united states will make that
decision but president biden has been
showing tremendous consistent leadership
doing exactly what he said he would do
and certainly in the foreign policy
realm which is my focus and
the reason i'm here
at the presidents and the secretary's
behest in the united kingdom is to
work every day to improve strengthen our
alliances our partnerships and there is
no better and more no more important
alliance than with the united kingdom
yeah i'm often asked whether when i'm
going to retire i give them my best
paddington stare and then we move on i
mean do you feel that the you know at 82
the president might be thinking about
wanting i mean he's been in politics all
his life i haven't asked him although i
had some very good conversations with
him on the margins of the cop
in glasgow last november uh and we were
very focused he was extremely energized
and animated by the issues at cop again
this is another inflection point as he's
talked about it uh the issue of climate
change uh almost existential
and uh we saw great
cooperation and working together with
the uk which was hosting 26 with the u.s
back in that paris process uh setting
some real goals for a net zero for this
important decade ahead and i think while
we deal with the challenges of energy
prices and other things it makes clear
that uh now is the time to be working
toward getting off those hydrocarbons
he's got lots to do and he's not ready
to put his feet up yet he's got a a lot
to do and he works hard every single day
that that i know quite well how
concerned do you think he might be about
president trump running next time you
know he's spoken to that uh obviously uh
people will decide parties will decide
who their candidates will be in 2024.
it's a long wait until 2024. it's around
the corner that isn't it you're almost
at the midterms midterms come midterms
go the institutions endure and what is
most important and what my focus is is
that uh our relationship not only endure
uh but thrive and that's what secretary
biden sent me here to focus on do you
think he might come over for the queen's
jubilee
you know i think the president has been
in the uk twice his uh two big trips uh
his first trips as president both
included the united kingdom uh i i know
he'll be watching uh we're all excited
and the admiration across the united
states beginning with president biden
for her majesty
uh is really quite something 70 years
imagine
what what that has encompassed and where
we have come frankly it's been 70 years
of uh
broadly peace and stability
in
uh
in this transatlantic space uh and i
think uh
i for one am a huge fan still here when
when we're waiting to see when the new
ambassador can arrive why is that
because we've had all of the rest of the
european countries they've got theirs
and no disrespect mr ambassador but
actually the okay i have to i have to
tell you there are a number of european
countries that don't as well
the uk is the only one the only country
where the secretary of state said we
need to send someone in my case the head
of the european bureau at the state
department an ambassador a career
diplomat who he asked to come here
and lead our mission our large and
diverse mission we have representatives
from some 44 u.s government departments
agencies bureaus that work with their uk
counterparts on a bilateral basis but
because it's london and because it's the
us and the uk it really has a global
impact
and that's what i'm doing here
and of course i've
promised the secretary i'll i'll stay
till the new ambassador who's been
nominated who is waiting for our process
to work we have a separation of powers
and now the legislative branch the
senate needs to have a hearing and offer
its advice i think that's been delayed
because of madeleine albright's funeral
i think that's right the hearing was
announced for the 27th and madeleine
albright for whom i worked
as a spokesman for many years uh passed
away of course and her funeral will be
on the 27th of april we're out of time
but i just
wondered what memories you'll be taking
away from london
oh there'll be so many but i think
perhaps the most important
uh that will always be with me is uh
september 11th last year 2021 when her
majesty the queen
not only instructed the uh the band at
the changing of the guard at windsor
castle to play the star-spangled banner
as she had done 20 years before after
that fateful day but she requested my
presence as the charge deferes there at
windsor castle that was an incredibly
moving moment for me to represent my
country
with our closest friends and allies uh
at this gesture that her majesty had
made and so it's a perfect opportunity
perhaps a day really to wish a very
happy 96th birthday to her majesty the
queen okay mr ambassador it's an honor
as always thank you so much for taking
the time we really appreciate it thanks
a lot thank you